êtes vous sûr en découvrant ces images
que vous connaissez bien votre région
avez vous assez écarté les pins pour
admirer au sud-est des landes la
californie d'aquitaine la chalosse une
contrée à l'image de sa capitale
saint-sever qualifié de cap de gascogne
fier de son passé de ses traditions une
contrée riche ouverte sur l'avenir
je vous invite à la découvrir le temps
d'une promenade
la chalosse et riche riche en céréales
comme le blé
mais c'est surtout le maïs qui
contribuent le plus à son évolution
joseph de pesquidoux écrit à ce propos
le maïs est employé à 1000 usage ses
feuilles arrachées vertes sont donnés
l'été au bétail toutes les volailles et
les porcs enfin engrais sont nourries
chez nous au maïs on engorge les oies
pour obtenir ces foies gras dont la
renommée est universel l'homme a aussi
consommer du maïs il en faisait jadis du
pain dans notre région
oui c'est ce fameux maïs qui fait la
renommée de ces volailles innocente
ou encore de sewa tranquille loin de se
douter de tout ce qu'elle représente l
s'ébattent joyeusement dans l'adour sans
savoir qu'elles feront bientôt le délice
des gourmets
c'est une même une lourde de renault
mais qu'elles portent ces pauvres bêtes
pour arroser dignement un bon foie gras
il faut bien sûr du vin remarquer au
milieu de ses vignobles un tracteur qui
prépare un champ de blé mise en jachère
avec le maïs mais nous parlons de 20 et
c'est bien sûr mugron le coeur des
vignobles et le grand centre de
production des vins de chalosse
charles de pesquidoux nous parler de
bétail
oui la chalosse fait aussi de l'élevage
élevage laitier d'ailleurs
pas deux trieuses électrique bien sûr
comme dans les grandes exploitations du
nord de la loire en chalosse il n'y a
que deux petits propriétaires et tout se
fait dans la tradition
jusqu au plumage de ces sois rentré à
jamais dans la tradition landaise
les gens de chalosse sont un peu du midi
et il aime à se déplacer sur une
terrasse de café devant un bon verre de
vin du pays ou encore se retrouver dans
leur capital saint-sever à l'occasion du
tour de france par exemple
ou d'un mariage
comme celui ci dans la charmante petite
église de toulousaine
la tradition est respectée avec la photo
de famille et puis tout le village
participe à la fête il y avait 200
invités à cette noce rendez vous compte
il
mais la chalosse c'est aussi le pays de
tourisme avec le lac dal coffret
d'hagetmau où il fait d'ailleurs bien
bon se promener l'été
e
pays de tourisme et mais aussi d'art
d'histoire avec son chapelet d'églises
romanes
mais c'est à joseph de pesquidoux que
revient le mot de la fin ceux qui
voyagent en emporte l'image sous les
paupières et ceux qui s'en vont pour ne
plus revenir en gare de l'incurable
nostalgie